[Music]
[Applause]
contestant number seven
nitaire
levy advice for life
advice for life nitaire levy
contest chair friends
that's how i laugh
sounds like a chihuahua mixed with a
goat
i love
like my mom
but you know what's worse than getting
her laugh
getting her advice
let's travel back in time
ready
i'm 17.
i'm in love with blue eyes
but
i'm too afraid to tell her
and my mom says
son
let me give you advice for life
always
show
your
love
she may give you a kiss
a kiss
the next day at school i say blue eyes
i love you
your dress
blue eye says
[Music]
weird but like
he's still gonna do my homework right
crushed
i rush home and i say mom
i hate your advice and i hate you
have you ever said i hate you
to someone you love
mom
puts her hand on my heart
son
you may hate me
but i
love
you
mom
showed me love
when i showed
none
you know what happens when you don't
show love
let's travel back in time
i'm 27
married to green eyes
when she wakes up
i'm at work
when she has dinner
i'm
at work
but when we are together
i'm thinking about
she often tells me
you're never here
i feel
so alone
and my mum never stops telling me
son
always show your love
show her you love her
i mean
do you always
show your love
green eyes
got tired of filling alone
packed her bags
and left me
i should have shown her
more love
because
when you show your love
i'll show you
i'm 37
single
i start boxing
and meet big brown eyes
with big red gloves
she says
hey
wanna box
[Music]
she punches me in the face
and i go to my boxing stance and i box
back
she says
cute
wanna go on a date
it was love at first fight
a year later
we went from the boxing ring
to a wedding ring
before long
big brown eyes tells me
you never hear
do you love me
and guess what my mom says
son
show her you love her
oh you will lose her
mum's right
so when big brown eyes wakes up i'm
there to tell her
i love you
when she has dinner i'm there to tell
her
i love you
when she asks wanna box
i'm there to tell her
nine months later
at the hospital
i hold a baby brown eyes girl
i filled her baby
and i know
how much love
my mom
showed
me when mom comes to the hospital
i whisper
mum
i
love you
and when mom sees baby brown eyes
she goes
and i go
we both go
[Music]
it's a love symphony
of a chihuahua mixed with a coat
do you show those you love
how much you love them
remember my mom's advice
as you travel through life
always
show
your
love
contesture
[Applause]